الشعب الاردني شعب يعشق فلسطين بكل
مكوناته وبالتالي اي خطوه من الحكومه
رسميا تكون لصالح الدفاع عن المسجد الاقصى
ستحظى بثقه كبيره وربما تساهم بردم الفجوه
الكبيره
بالثقه بسبب الاحوال المعيشيه والاقتصاديه
البائسه ولكن الشعب الاردني على الرغم من
فقره وعلى الرغم من الجوع وعلى الرغم من
البطاله وعلى الرغم من كل المشاكل اللي
معي شيء ولا اقتصاديه الا انه عند الحديث
عن المسجد الاقصى فهذا يكون خط احمر حقيقي
والجميع الاردني يتحولوا الى فدائيين
واستشهاديين من اجل فلسطين ومن اجل الاقصى
قبل ايام كان جلاله الملك على السي ان
وقال ان تم تجاوز الخطوط الحمر لنا كردن
ستكون هناك ردت فعله سيكون هناك انطلب
المواجهه فنحن لها
وبالتالي بعد كلام الملك تم خ- يعني
الخطوط الحمر تم تجاوزها بعد يومين وعندما
يتم الاكتفاء باستدعاء السفير وكانه لا
يوجد لدينا ادوات ولا يوجد لدينا رده فعل
سوى هذا الموقف انا اقول يجب ان الحكومه
ان تكون على مستوى الحدث بل واكون واضح في
كلامي على الدوله وعلى الدوله العميقه
وعلى جميع مؤسسات الدوله ان يكون لك رده
فعل قويه لن ابالغ ولن اقول اننا نريد ان
نحرك الجيوش وان نعلن التعبئه لتحرير
فلسطين سياتي هذا اليوم وان شاء الله ان
لا يكون بعيدا ونحن نعلم ان ظهرنا مكشوف
من العالم العربي قبل الاسلام قبل العالمي
والجميع متخلي عن الاردن ولن نطلب من
الاردن ان يتصدى وحيدا لهذه المساله
وبالتالي لكن اقول انه ذلك اوراق جزء منها
تفضل بها ابو عماد على مستوى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه وجزء منها اقول ان يتم
دعم مباشر لاهلنا المرابطين والمرابطات في
المسجد الاقصى الا يتم اي تضيق عليهم وهم
يعانوا من بعض الصديقات ان يتم من
الانفتاح على جميع المكونات الفلسطينيه
هنالك شيخ في القدس وفي المسجد الاقصى
يعبر عن رمز للامه العربيه والاسلاميه في
الدفاع عن القدس والمسجد الاقصى قصرنا معه
الفتره الماضيه اتحدث عن الشيخ رائد صلاح
اتحدث عن مكون فلسطيني يمثل على الاقل 50%
من فلسطين يجب ان ننفتح عليه ويجب ان يعيد
العلاقات معه وهذه قرصه اذن بتكون
والحكومه المتطرفه اتحدث بالتاكيد عن حركه
حماس وانا اتوافق مع زميلي خالد ابو حسان
هذا من [__] وابو حسين ابناء القرده
والخنازير يجب ان يعلمه بان الرد من الشعب
الاردني والفلسطيني الان ربما يسمع الكلام
ولكن هذا الكلام يعبر عن بركان قادم لان
الرد سيكون بالرصاص قريبا باذن الله